لا ، لكن الأمر مختلف عن
واشنطن ولندن ، ربما ينبغي أن نعلمهم
كيفية إدارة بلد بدون ميزانية
لأن لبنان الذي تعرفه
يتكيف مع كل موقف صعب
وأعتقد أننا سنكون قادرين قريبًا على تشكيل
حكومة والخروج منها.  هذا
الوضع الذي يكون فيه اقتصادنا في حاجة حقيقية
لإعادة تشكيله ، فلنتحدث
عن الاقتصاد لأنه لأكون صريحًا
يقف على حافة الانهيار في الوقت الحالي
، يصفه الكثيرون بأنه أمر
مزعج يحتجون على
كل شيء من الفساد
إلى انقطاع التيار الكهربائي والاقتصاد.  تم الإبلاغ عن
ضخ ما يقرب من مليار دولار
من كاتا وهي
خطوة مثيرة للجدل إلى حد كبير بالنظر إلى
سياسات المنطقة ، هل هذه حالة من المتسولين
لا يمكن أن يكونوا مختارين في هذه المرحلة لا يمكنني
وصفها على أنها أن اقتصادنا
سيء للغاية كما تعلم  لأنه اقتصاد صغير
، يمتلك الشعب اللبناني
مبادرة رائعة ويمكننا إحيائه
بسهولة جدًا بنسبة GD P في العالم
ونعم ولكننا ما زلنا قادرين على القيام بذلك
لأننا  استخدم مرة أخرى ، فنحن واسعي الحيلة
ويمكننا القيام بذلك ،
لدينا مهارات لدينا القدرة على القيام
بذلك ولدينا دول لا تزال تؤمن
ليفين الذين لا يزالون
يؤمنون بالحاجة إلى النموذج اللبناني
لمواجهة أو ما نواجهه و
لا أعتقد أن الأمر سيستغرق أي شخص حتى
يكون لبنان منهارًا مثل نموذج يضحك
من لبنان ، ما نتيجة
ذلك لأن المزيد من الإرهاب هو المزيد من التطرف
والمزيد من العنف.